good morning heck it's tuesday i'm sick
which is perhaps related to the fact
that i recently spent a lot of time with
strangers in the louvre looking at this
painting called liberty leading the
people by eugene delacroix which first
and foremost is not about the french
revolution okay so we're going to gloss
over a lot of complexity to get to why
this painting is so great but you'll
recall that in the late 18th century
there was a french revolution during
which the king louis xvi and his wife
who never actually said let them eat
cake were removed from power and then a
couple years later france entered the
so-called reign of terror where over 16
000 people were executed by the state
french politician max million
robespierre famously wrote at this time
the basis of popular government during a
revolution is both virtue and terror
although some would argue he was a
little stronger on the terror than the
virtue but anyway then in 1799 napoleon
bonaparte became the de facto leader of
france eventually crowning himself
emperor and who would succeed napoleon
why king louis xv who was literally the
previous louie's brother so in about 20
years france went from having a king
named louis to having a democratic
revolution to having an emperor to
having another king named louie who was
the old louie's brother that's often the
thing about revolutions
they go all the way around okay so we've
got this new louis but then in 1824 he
dies of both wet and dry gangrene which
is a nice reminder that i would not like
to live in the 19th century even if i
could be a king and so his other brother
charles the tenth becomes king he tries
to rule over france in partnership with
this parliament called the chamber of
deputies but it goes terribly and
finally in 1830 king charles the tenth
attempts to dissolve parliament and
reinstate all of these bans on press
freedom this leads to the july
revolution where charles the 10th is
removed from power and enter into the
scene the citizen king louis philippe
who's allowed to be king but also has to
be a citizen and this constitutional
monarchy is going to be mostly
constitutional that is the revolution
depicted in this painting by then france
had been an unstable country for almost
50 years right veering back and forth
between democracy and monarchy and
populist tyrannical governments and
military dictatorships there had been
endless bloodshed and this is a painting
about all of that about the hope of
liberty leading the people of course but
also about the fear as shown by the fact
that liberty is walking among corpses
it's about the cost of revolution as
well as the promise of it i mean there
is glory here but there is also lots of
death while making this painting de la
cua wrote if i haven't fought for my
country i'll at least paint for her and
it does feel to me like a painting for
the french people in this historical
moment a painting that celebrates the
audacious hope of revolution while also
acknowledging the risk of failure in
revolution another thing i really love
about the painting is the way it gets
kind of unfinished looking in the
background like these distant stories
and distant people are as yet unfixed
which makes me think about how we can't
know what history means as we live
through it delacroix couldn't know that
the july revolution wouldn't be the end
of french revolutions or french monarchs
the painting was bought the year after
it was finished by the french government
with the initial idea being to hang it
somewhere near king louis philippe to
remind him that constitutional
monarchies should remain constitutional
but louis philippe's allies deemed it
too radical so it was hidden in an attic
until it was displayed again in 1848 as
a new revolution came to france the
painting didn't enter the collection of
the louvre until 1874 just after the
death of france's last ever monarch
napoleon iii to look at the painting now
it seems like a celebration of the
inevitable victory of liberty and
democracy but it wasn't not when it was
painted and not for decades afterward
because there was nothing inevitable
about the victory of liberty and
democracy there still isn't to me the
painting is a reminder that revolutions
are never easy or simple even when
liberty is leading the people
hank i'll see you on friday